welcome to another edition of The Gadget
Lab show I'm Christina Bonnington and I
am at the Baldwin or Robbie Robbie's
fine yeah it's kind of a ginger addition
this week we're gonna take a look at it
Nexus zenbook a headset that lets you
control games with your mind and a look
at Star Wars 35th anniversary so first
up what do you have to show us this week
Robbie so I have the asus zenbook it is
an ultrabook i think we all know
ultrabooks basically windows editions of
MacBook Airs yeah this one's from Asus
and you can get it for it when it's a
minutes available on the market will be
from eight hundred dollars to sixteen
hundred dollars so you get the whole
gamut you can be able to get a Ivy
Bridge processors in here from the i3 i5
i7 is this is actually a really good
little machine it's got the machined
metal look yeah i love the brush
aluminum kayla yeah it's really nice
feels nice it feels like you could chop
something stuck with it so that's nice
um it has a way compared to the macbook
air um it's relatively about the same i
mean you're talking about like like
ounces and like point you know at some
point no one really it's like
millimeters some people are talk about
millimeters difference between like
ultra blocks and i know it's like what
half a millimeter smaller yeah who's
there battling for that though yeah yeah
point 01 millimeters thinner than the
last one yes it's whoop-dee-doo um it
has a nice chiclet keyboard so you know
like kind of like the macbook air it I
hate saying I keep saying macbook air
but unfortunately that's pretty much for
all these manufacturers are looking for
it does have some really nice bang &
olufsen speakers so it sounds really
really good the touchpad man not so much
but this the display is really nice and
you're not going to be able to tell them
you know see it here but I assure you
it's a very nice display it is not
available now and this is actually a
technology preview so this is even this
is
even in the final production model so it
might get smaller it might get better
but if this is I'm guessing prob about
ninety nine to five percent done
technology previews it's kind of like
looking into the future with binoculars
that are a little bit fade yeah so when
can i buy that if I want it I have no
idea yeah just some time later this year
yeah yeah sometime later this year well
it looks nice yeah yeah it's a nice
little machine the asus zenbook if
you're in the market for a windows 7
ultrabook nice pretty nice this week I
took a look at this mindwave mobile
headsets yeah you use your minds yeah
things so I I'll put it on you feel real
cool wearing this thing so it goes on
its got like a head band across the top
you put it on there's a piece that goes
behind your ears now like I've got like
all this hair I've got to move hold on I
don't even have that much hair I can't
imagine if I had long hair and was
trying to do this and then it has this
EEG sensor on the front and with that it
senses your mind waves and what's really
detecting is changes in the electrical
impulses on your on your skin I'm going
to tell you right now skeptical very
skeptical of your weird creepy thing
stuck in your head does it look good you
know if you wore that this is what you
would buy for your child if it was going
to prom and you were concerned about
their virginity because no one will lose
their virginity wearing this in public
yeah oh man and so it's also got this
sensor on the ear but you have to clip
on and so it's kind of hard to adjust
sometimes and if you don't adjust it
right it can start to slip the wrong way
and it kind of pulls on your ear so
that's kind of uncomfortable but
identify it seemed to work so it can
measure how relaxed you are how focused
you are and it can also tell just based
on muscle movements if you believe
you're blinking and so there's all these
different games you can play and you
know there's combination
of those things you know some of the
games like there was a tug of war game
and you've got to focus as hard as you
can to try to beat the opponent and
other times you may need to be relaxed
and very zen and so you've got to focus
your mind on either being relaxed or
like concentrating and then winner now
with you when you tried it at any point
did you just take it off put on the
ground and then play the game and see
what happens you know I didn't do that
but I did try to lose and I lost when I
tried to lose cuz I because it seemed
you know maybe I just have phenomenal
mind powers maybe maybe not um do you
have to do this at any point because
people who use mine controlling the
movies are always doing this I should be
like your tempo is like some sort of
like brain trigger yeah I have to try
that next time yeah try that yeah but so
this is one hundred thirty dollars wow
it's devan now and there's a lot of
games for it i think including pc and
mac games there's around 100 but a lot
of them aren't free so this isn't a
cheap thing you know if you want to get
the most out of it you've got to
purchase few games it does come bundled
with some um some free ones but only
games that are made for specifically for
this headset dr coletti okay i'm gonna
take it off now her now but it's cool i
mean it's interesting it's kind of a
novelty it's kind of a kind of a gimmick
but seemed seem to work in our tests
only professor extra real he could
really give it a whirl so if you're a
nerd or a geek or really anyone who's
under 60 probably you're probably pretty
excited and you probably know that is
the 35th anniversary of Star Wars a new
hope
doing a lot of posts unwired about Star
Wars because we are yeah you can't yeah
I have a love-hate relationship with
Star Wars I love Star Wars but I hate
the fact that every time they do
anything any little peripheral or its
license for anything I'm excited you
hate that you get excited I hate that no
it's just like but it's it's the same
thing over and over again if there was a
star Star Wars cereal if I'm walking
tall oh maybe I should get that I don't
want Star Wars cereal but yet I can't
help myself oh man did you go see Star
Wars when it was released in 3d no I
don't watch TV movie since waste of
money actually I do go see 3d movies but
I was just too busy go see the star wars
this time um yeah so what is your
favorite part of Star Wars a new hope my
favorite part of stars new hope is when
Han Solo is running after all the
stormtroopers please let yeah he's
charging and then they realize it's one
guy in a vest and then they come back
any runs back it's a nice it's a nice
moment he shows his sort of bravado
character but it's also you know it's
laced with some humor so good times yeah
that's a good part I think mine would
have to be the cantina scene went on
shoots first yes he did he shot first
he's a he's a rascal that's that house
alone all right well I guess we'll see
you next week on The Gadget Lab show